Well, to solve this, we can plug in C equals 360 over alpha,
which was 7.2 degrees times D, which is 5000 stadia.
When we did this out with the degree is cancelled--we get a
value for the circumference of 250,000 stadia.
Now we're still not done because we need to convert--we're going to take our number
250,000 stadia times 185 meters in 1 stadium and we want to convert that to kilometers
so we'll multiply it by 1 kilometer for every 1000 meters.
When we do this, we get a final answer of 46,250 kilometers. Amazing!
We did this all just with some shadows, some basic knowledge of geometry,
and a little bit of trigonometry that we have to learn as well
Not only is it amazing that we could calculate the circumference using such basic knowledge,
but the skills that we gained in doing so are skills we used throughout this course--congratulations!
Now, let's see the experiment in action.